thanks to brilliant for helping support
this episode
hey crazies ancient humans really wanted
Earth to be the center of the universe
to be fair when we look into the sky it
certainly seems like the universe is
revolving around us so it's only natural
we came up with wacky models all just to
explain our weird observations
of course in modern times we have a
simpler explanation Earth revolves
around the Sun or does it
oh
[Music]
before you blow the lid off your brain
I'm not saying that modern astrophysics
is wrong I'm just saying there's a
Nuance here you may not have considered
but before we get into that we need some
history
to the timeline
there's evidence we were tracking
celestial objects as early as 40 000
years ago cave paintings showing phases
of the moon were commonplace although
people that far back didn't know the
Earth was a sphere we wouldn't figure
that out until we started traveling
longer distances you know venturing into
the ocean and making world maps and
stuff like that but that didn't stop us
from tracking celestial objects in the
meantime many historical monuments were
built expressly for that purpose
my point is tracking objects in the sky
is a time-honored tradition among humans
mostly just for time keeping though we
had to know when to do stuff
explaining why celestial objects move
the way they do well that was a bit more
niche niche Niche ah whatever
back in ancient Greece like 2400 years
ago they loved geocentric models
geocentric meaning earth-centered that's
the literal translation
to give you an example imagine a model
with Earth at the center of the universe
and because the ancient Greeks were
absolutely obsessed with geometry Earth
was surrounded by eight concentric
spheres seven for the sky Wanderers and
one for the Stars
the sky Wanderers yep and I'm sure
you've heard of all of them from inside
to outside the moon Mercury Venus the
sun Mars Jupiter and Saturn are most of
those planets yeah and this is actually
where the word planet comes from
planetos means Wanderer in ancient Greek
okay okay so why are they called
Wanderers because they wander against
the background Stars let's say one night
we observe Mars to be here in the sky we
can record its position in relation to
all the surrounding stars but then the
next night we check again and notice its
position has changed it was here last
night but now it's here tonight which
seems a little sus so we keep checking
to see what happens
on night number three it's here night
four here night five here and so on Mars
wanders the same goes for the other six
planets yes they called both the moon
and the sun planets back then so stop
being grumpy about Pluto being
reclassified the moon and the sun were
reclassified too and we don't think less
of them anyway each of the seven
Wanderers were on their own rotating
sphere it creates a mechanism that shows
how they can wander
but it didn't take us very long to
figure out this was wrong
all you have to do is watch Mars for a
little while longer and you'll notice
something strange at very regular
intervals it backtracks a little before
continuing on its way we call this
retrograde motion and the concentric
sphere model doesn't explain it there's
no mechanism for it I suppose they could
have said a God steps in and does it but
that wouldn't really be the ancient
Greek style while they did believe in
powerful Gods those gods were also messy
imperfect and never said to be the
creators of the universe would you want
it being like that messing up the
Perfection of nature which finally
brings us to Ptolemy back to the
timeline it took about 530 years but a
guy named tolomeus or Ptolemy for short
proposed a fix rather than spheres
Ptolemy imagined planets revolved around
the earth on circular orbits although he
didn't call them orbits in a single
orbit still didn't explain retrograde
motion a type of motion that five of the
seven Wanderers exhibited so he didn't
stop at a single orbit for those five
for each of the planets Ptolemy imagined
one large circle around earth called a
deferent a point on this deferent
revolved around the Earth but that point
wasn't the planet the planet itself was
on a second circle called an epicycle
centered on that point each planet
orbited along its epicycle while the
epicycle orbited along its deference
tuned properly he could explain
retrograde motion sometimes the planets
wandered backward it also explained why
their brightness changed sometimes they
were closer to Earth sometimes they were
farther away so success not so fast
watching a planet like Mars very closely
you'll notice another Minor Detail it's
not always going the same speed
for ptolemy's model to work the planets
had to change orbital speed throughout
the year unacceptable so what did he do
more episodes actually no that's a
historical myth the way the story is
usually told is that Ptolemy added
epicycle upon epicycle until it worked
would that have worked absolutely it's
just Fourier series it'll work on any
shape but that wouldn't be discovered
until 1807 CE
Ptolemy didn't do this his orbits never
had more than one epicycle it's a myth
but he was definitely in a bit of a
pickle he needed a solution and he opted
for one a little simpler than extra
epicycles Ptolemy zoomed in on Earth and
asked himself what if the Earth isn't
perfectly at the center what if it's off
just a tiny amount it's still Center ish
just not perfectly centered of course
this didn't go over well at first but
this tiny fix actually worked at least
to the Precision they were capable of
measuring at the time in fact this model
was so good at predicting the motion of
celestial objects that it was
essentially the word of the Gods for
1500 years oh the arrogance but
predictability alone does not make a
model correct sun-centered or
heliocentric models are far superior
they're not only simpler they're more
accurate too and they predicted later
observations like stellar parallax
that's what a nearby star wobbles
slightly against the background Stars
that wouldn't be possible if Earth
didn't move through space
wait didn't you start this whole
discussion by saying the Earth could be
at the center did I
Earth revolves around the Sun or does it
oh I guess I did where were you going
with that reference frames those ancient
earth-centered models were a mistake but
the mistake wasn't that Earth was at the
center it was that they equated the
center with importance and we still kind
of make this mistake sometimes
these days we say the sun is at the
center of the solar system but what we
should really be saying is that the sun
is in control of the solar system
Newtonian physics tells us that mass
causes gravity and that gravity is what
controls a planetary system the sun
contains 99.8 percent of the mass of the
solar system which means it's always in
control that can't be disputed but that
doesn't mean the sun has to be at the
center it just means putting the Sun at
the center results in the simplest
picture a fundamental truth of the
universe is that all objects observe
themselves to be stationary motion is
measured from a reference and the
easiest reference is oneself putting
Earth at the center of your measurements
is a perfectly valid point of view it's
the point of view of all humans standing
on the earth you can Center your
coordinates wherever you want as long as
you obey the laws of physics do you want
Earth to be the center of the solar
system that's fine as long as the sun is
still in control what would that look
like complicated if we stick with
tradition and put the Sun at the center
the model is simple all the planets
including Earth orbit the Sun and
elliptical paths just as Johannes Kepler
imagined in 1604 CE retrograde motion is
caused by the motion of each planet
relative to a moving Earth to give you
some perspective I've stabilized the sky
in this class our planet Earth is a
giant rock tumbling through space
our coordinates though the path s of the
planets aren't so simple anymore this
isn't particularly beautiful but it's
physically accurate
accurate and it's what we see from Earth
from this point of view retrograde
motion happens because of a complicated
path relative to a stationary Earth
this is the point of view we actually
have where the sky moves around us all
we did was change the coordinates and
coordinates are just a tool which
coordinates you'll want to use depends
on the question you're trying to answer
foreign
if you like science questions you should
check out today's sponsor brilliant
brilliant is a tool for learning stem
interactively you can play around with
Concepts in real time working with
science yourself is honestly the best
way to learn new skills in math science
and computer science if you like this
video you'll probably like their course
on gravitational physics there's a whole
section full of lessons and quizzes on
orbital mechanics you can learn about
how the planets orbit in ellipses and
about the math behind those patterns if
that isn't what you're into brilliant
has thousands of lessons with new
content added monthly it's college level
content for everyone
if you want to get started with a free
trial go to brilliant.org science Asylum
or click the link in the description
below
the first 200 of you will get 20 off
brilliant's annual premium subscription
it'll also let brilliant know you heard
about them from me which helps out the
channel
so who is the center of your universe
let us know in the comments Thanks for
liking and sharing this video
a special Thanks goes out to all my
patreon patrons and YouTube members for
all their generous support
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember
okay to be a little crazy
I've been informed by many commenters
that phone chargers aren't Transformers
anymore
just to be you know back in the ancient
days of the 90s and the early 2000s but
apparently they switched over to
something called a switch mode power
supply must have happened when the
chords upgraded to USB
anyway thanks for the correction and
thanks for watching